volume validates or invalidates price
action. And I'm going to explain exactly
how that works in this video. Hey guys,
what's going on? Mr. Zinc here. In
today's video, I'm going to break down
exactly how I use volume on Trading View
to validate or invalidate my setups.
Let's get right into it. First things
first, what you're going to want to do
is go onto Trading View, go to
indicators, look up volume, favorite it,
and activate volume. It is the only one
that just says volume. All the other
indicators are things that use volume.
We're only worrying about what the
volume does itself. Go into the dropown
menu in your top left. Activate V. That
stands for volume. Once you have it
active, yours will be red and green.
Here is the color that I use for my red
bars on volume. I prefer not to have red
on my chart for several reasons. I'll
cover that in a later video. This is the
color I use
here. Great. Now that you have volume
activated, I'm going to show you exactly
how I use it to validate or invalidate
my setups. For these volume pillars,
what you want to see is price coincide
with the strength or size of the volume
pillar. For instance, on April 9th, we
had a 13.6% day up on Q's. Volume was
also extremely high. Whereas for the
following week, week and a half even, as
price decreased, so didn't the volume.
volume went down as price went down,
which indicates that that is an invalid
move to the downside, meaning that
you're looking for an area to go long or
a setup to have a nice breakout of that
pattern. Now, that you can see once we
did break out of that structure, volume
also broke with price action, meaning
that that was a valid move to the
upside. Past three days have been a
valid move to the upside. Now, what we'd
be looking for is either consolidation
sideways with volume decreasing as it
consolidates, or we'd look for a
continuation up with continued price
action or volume to the upside. Going
over to Bitcoin and reading this chart
just because it looks so clean. We're
going to break down exactly why I have a
price target set to 95,000 on Bitcoin.
First things first, I saw the April 9th
day with a volume that came in on
Bitcoin as well as the 8% pop up. The
very next day, we had a 3.7% print to
the downside. But where was volume? Just
about a third of the previous day. As we
consolidated sideways on Bitcoin, we had
eight days within the same inside bar or
mother bar that we printed on Saturday,
April 12th. That bar was 2.2%. The
following eight trading days were all
within that 2% range. What did volume do
for the following eight trading days?
Volume decreased and went down. What
happened once we broke out of that
structure out of that inside bar? Volume
had a pump up to about 2x the highest
volume day within that 8day
consolidation period. What happened on
Tuesday, April 22nd, when we continued
that move to the upside? volume came in
even higher again Wednesday we had an
even higher print in volume not from
Tuesday but a higher print from Monday
and then today Thursday April 24th what
happened when price action started to
reverse volume went absolutely nowhere
dropped out the window we had about half
the volume we did on the continuation
day on Wednesday what this is telling me
is that we are still in an uptrend on
Bitcoin we still want higher we're just
cooling off for the time being. Price
action cannot go straight in one
direction for an extended period of time
without cooling off. How you read that
is you look for volume to cool off. If
you have an uptrend, as we did on the
15minut time frame today on Q's, if you
have an uptrend, anytime you see
consolidation or sideways price action
in that trend, always go and look at
what volume is doing. For instance,
today on Q's, we went sideways
for about an hour and a half, 11 o'clock
to
12:15. What did volume do in that time
frame? Volume also decreased all the way
until 12. What happened once we had a
break of structure at 12:15? Look at the
volume candle that came in with that.
Volume continued to increase from the
previous decreasing candles. We
consolidated again for about another two
hours, hour and a half, two hours, and
then we had a continuation to the upside
with a very strong 4hour close on Q's
today. Going to the 4our time frame, we
can see exactly where price action comes
in, where the volume comes in at which
point of the day. The first bar that you
see that spiked up is your first half of
the trading day. Second bar is your
second half. If volume comes in with a
strong print while price action is going
up or down, that validates the move. If
volume comes in with a weak print as
price action is going up or down, that
invalidates the move. What you want to
see when you have price action going in
one direction is you want to see volume
also line up in that direction. For
instance, if you have a red candle come
in, but the volume is looking something
like this at the bottom of the screen,
that red candle is probably
invalidated. Same thing for a green
candle. If you have a green candle
coming in with very minimal volume
associated with it, it's probably an
invalid move. I like to use this on the
24-hour time frame, especially when
we're consolidating. Um, as we
previously covered, volume was
decreasing from April 9th and then once
we broke that structure Tuesday, April
22nd, volume spiked up as well and then
continued to spike into Wednesday. What
you want to see is just strong volume
pillars with the direction that price is
going. Let's go over and analyze
Wednesday, April 2nd to uh Friday, April
4th, when we had those three consecutive
4% down days on Q's. What did volume do?
volume validated that move. We had
Wednesday, April 2nd print a decently
high candle uh for volume volume pillar.
Thursday, April 3rd came in even higher,
validating that move to the downside.
Friday came in the highest out of those
three days, further validating that
downside. We had a 6% print to the
downside. Pretty much no buying pressure
for the day. Volume validated that move
to the downside.
Monday comes around, we gap down 4% on
Q's, end up closing up
1.6%. What did volume tell us? Volume
told us that that was an extremely valid
move. So, what we are doing here is
we're changing our state and delivery.
We're looking for a different move or a
pivot in price
action. What does volume do the
following day? We have a retracement of
4%. Volume was about half the print of
Monday, April 7th's candle. That tells
us that this was an invalid move on
Tuesday, April 8th. So, we should be
looking long for the following day,
Wednesday, April 9th. What happened? We
had news come out with from Trump saying
that terrorists were going to be paused.
Volume told the story this entire time.
Same thing for Monday, April 21st. I
actually posted this within all my
socials and the Discord that I'm in.
Volume told the story for all all of
Monday, April uh 21st. Go to the 4 hour
time frame. Go to Monday, April 21st.
The first half of the day, I'm going to
zoom in on this so we can really see it.
We're looking at these two candles right
here. The first half of the day when we
had that 3.5% drop, volume was pretty
lackluster, right? It wasn't really
present. Whereas for the second part of
the day, when we had a pretty good move
up, we had about a $5 move up on Q's
within 30 minutes. volume told us that
that was a valid move to the upside. So,
we should be looking long for the
following day. Go to the 24-hour time
frame. What happened after Monday, April
21st? We had a crazy 4% expansion to the
upside. Volume came in about twice the
size of the previous day and then
continued to print on Wednesday. And
that's exactly what you want to look
for. It doesn't matter what chart you're
going to go look at. Let's go take a
look at Tesla. Go to the 24-hour time
frame. I know I have a bunch of lines on
here. This is from another video. Let me
delete the Fibonacci
retracement. Tesla, same exact thing.
And this is exactly why I was long
heading into earnings on Tesla. What did
volume do after April 9th? We had a move
to the downside on Tesla. Volume also
drastically decreased over those eight
trading days. Straight down on
volume, a slow, steady move down on
price action. This is a controlled
sell-off. This is getting people out of
their positions by manipulating price to
the downside with weak volume. Then what
happens? We have a 10% day with pretty
high volume. I mean, this volume was
higher than almost all of those days to
the
downside. Wednesday, April 23rd, volume
continued to the upside. Thursday, same
exact thing. We had another 3.5%
expansion. What I'll be looking for for
tomorrow, Friday, April 25th, is a
further expansion. Probably going to go
test those Wednesday highs at 277. This
is just how Tesla moves. It's extremely
volatile. It likes to move 10, $13 in a
day. So 277 is well on the table for
Friday, April 25th. All I'm getting at
here is that volume is going to tell you
the entire story of the candle without
even looking at the candle. If I
scrolled all the way down back to the
beginning of the video when we were just
looking at volume, what this tells me,
this initial candle right here tells me
that we have a very, very strong buying
pressure for that day. We have
incredible buying pressure for that day.
What happens after volume takes a nose
dive? What I'd be looking for is a break
out with
volume before even looking at price. I
want to see volume spike up. When volume
starts to overtake those previous days
of that downtrend, that means you're
you're validated to go long or short,
depending on what side that volume's
crossing. In this case, it was crossing
to the upside. It had about three hours
left in the day to overtake that volume.
So, if you hit the equal volume from a
previous downtrend or the equal volume
from a previous uptrend with plenty of
trading left on the day, that tells you
that you should probably be going long
or short or inversing that trend that
you had for the past seven to eight
trading days. You can do this with any
chart as the volume is present on any
chart that you have. If we want to go
take a look at Google heading into
earnings today, for instance, Google had
a a pretty explosive earnings today.
What did volume tell us? Volume told us
that as we were dropping in price
action, volume had a small increase and
then it took a pretty hard nose dive on
Monday, April 21st. We had Tuesday,
April 22nd print equal volume to Monday
and then that expansion started on
Wednesday, April 23rd. Now the earnings
is out. Look at the volume spike that we
have with a validation to the upside of
70.3%. 7.3, sorry.
volume is telling us that we should
continue a long bias heading into
tomorrow, April 25th, because it's
beating out pretty much all the
downtrend that we had for the past seven
trading days, and it's going to continue
to push price action to the upside
because buyers are stepping in, and
they're stepping in rather aggressively.
Go and look at
Apple. Apple is actually in a pretty
good spot right now. We're coming up to
a decently large uh resistance level uh
209 210 just about. What is volume
doing? Volume is selling off pretty
hard. So volume's decreasing while price
action is remaining flat, meaning that
it's
consolidating. As soon as we break out
of this range, let me get rid of these
other lines so it looks a little
cleaner. As soon as we get indication
that this is going to break this range
209 210, we want to see volume come in
in the earlier half of the day and we
want to ride that wave up with a trend.
First price target on this will be the
next resistance level all the way up
here at
224. So if Apple comes in, let's say
tomorrow, April 25th, Apple comes prints
a a pretty large volume candle to start
the day. The first 4hour candle beats
out all these previous days. As price
actions is consolidating, that volume
candle comes
prints the same volume within the first
four hours of market. For the next four
hours of market, we're looking to go
long to the next resistance level. In
this case, it's 224. Now, let's say
Apple starts to sell off and reaches the
bottom of that trend again at 192. While
volume continues to sell off, then we'll
do the same thing just to the short
side.
I hope this all made sense and I hope
that you start using volume with all
your trading strategies moving forward
because it really does tell the whole
story. It tells you exactly what you
need to see while you're trading and it
tells you what the move is going to be
before it even happens because big money
positions themselves before retail does.
If you take advantage of looking at
volume, you're going to take advantage
of what big money is doing and you're
going to get a jump start on everyone
else. I'll catch you guys later this
week for another video. I hope you have
a great rest of your day, great rest of
your week. Peace out.